now unemployment claimants are reacting
to yet another court order
implemented yesterday the state's
unemployment department must pay a
certain group of claimants by a certain
date joe moeller has been following this
hearing over the past few days he joins
us live with reaction joe
well kirsten after failing to meet the
first court order which was issued in
the summer
dieter must now meet the second one that
was issued yesterday by that judge to
get
a handful of thousands of pua claimants
paid
now some people i spoke with today some
claimants say they're still worried this
won't happen with
the issues that are continuing i think
it's finally
spotlighted what is really going on on
the inside what is really going on with
this system
but it's just still not enough amber
hansen runs a popular facebook group to
help claimants
she watched the eight-hour pua hearing
thursday where a judge ruled theater is
in contempt after not following a court
order to pay thousands of claims
i think the fines should have been
stiffer i think that they should have
had to pay
a thousand dollars for every single
person that they have wrongfully not
paid or stopped payments on that's my
opinion
deter was fined one thousand dollars and
also told to pay roughly 9 000 claimants
who had payments started and stopped by
december 24th
i feel like three more weeks to try to
get it together um
i wish them the best of luck but i feel
like they've created such a nightmare
and a mess
with the overpayment situation and the
math denials i think that
you know like i've told you many times
before she thinks a more clear direction
on the claims process
and more communication could help moving
forward during the hearing we heard from
three claimants who explained their
problems and experiences
nobody wanted to acknowledge in that
hearing that the phone system was
lackluster
that they have problems with having
enough people answering the phone they
just wanted to turn it around on the
witnesses
i've uploaded all my documentation today
i spoke to garrick mark hebden who has
been waiting eight months to get paid he
also watched the hearing
a lot of the the witnesses the three
witnesses
uh had the same issues and then
all of a sudden this morning everything
just got released
he thinks he was paid because of what
happened in the hearing but there isn't
a way to find out
he was never given a reason as to why he
wasn't being paid i think
that i was being held with payment for
no reason
well hanson says this is a step in the
right direction with the ruling that
came down yesterday but there's still a
lot of other people
out there including people who are
waiting for appeals uh people who are
waiting for their initial claim to be
refute who are not one of those people
who are
started and stopped so there's still a
lot of other people out there who with
some problems she said she hopes some
other issues can be fixed as well to get
the whole entire system addressed
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now